One second. Hello? Oh, you got a phone call. I'm just doing this intro thing with Sean. With Sean from, yeah. Hey, you want to finish with me first and then take a call? One second, Sean. This is very important. Yes, host of the year. Sean, he's...
Why don't we start the show? Sean, one second. I'm going to be there. Why are you so... Why don't we just start the show and then you can take a call? This is an important business call. Just give me one second. Yeah, I'm just chilling. What's going on with you? Guys, welcome to Smartlist. Smart!
Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! All right, real quick announcement here, right up at the top. Good news, bad news kind of thing. Dark day for sweet Willie Arnett.
It's a bummer, we're not gonna, because of everything that's going on in the world, we are unfortunately gonna have to cancel our Toronto shows. So sorry to all our Toronto friends. And just so people understand, it's due to current capacity restrictions and the uncertain timeline of those limitations that we have to cancel the Toronto show.
And they can get refunds, right? Yes, the good news is that a refund will be processed automatically if you bought tickets. If you bought tickets directly from Ticketmaster, I think is the caveat. But let's tell them where we're going instead. The new city is. Washington DC.
Wait, what? Yes, February 2nd. The same day as the Toronto show, but now since we're now doing Toronto, we're doing DC February 2nd at D.A.R. Constitution Hall in D.C. And for our listeners, you can use the special password Tracey,
T-R-A-C-E-Y to buy tickets now until Thursday at 10 p.m. before they go on sale for the public. And those tickets are already on sale. Yeah, so they can already get those tickets and you can go, if you go and you use the promo code Tracey, T-R-A-C-E-Y, you can get tickets now in advance of the public up till Thursday, is that right?
Yeah, so now until Thursday for all our listeners, use the password T-R-A-C-E-Y. You can also go to smartlist.com slash tour for tickets and more information. Smartlist.com slash tour. Never go to the post office again. So we're very sorry, Toronto. We love you, Canada.
We will return. We love you so much. We know we have a lot of fans in Toronto and D.C., we can't wait to see you at Constitution Hall and that's great in February 2nd. And anyway, let's get to the show. Let's get to the show. Let's get to the show.
This is odd, isn't it? We're doing a little Monday matinee. Listen, I've got shoes on. I don't think I've had shoes on for how many episodes have we done now? Yeah. It's the first one. And you're wearing a nice crew neck.
Yeah, well, I dare you, it's a sweater. Yeah, I guess. That's what I mean, it's a crew neck sweater. It looks like a cash sweater. It is cash. It's a crew neck sweater. You guys are also wearing, Will, you're wearing a crew neck sweater.
Slight V. Slight crew neck and Sean's wearing a Henley collar. But he's wearing a Henley with a T-shirt. Is it a sweater? We all have T-shirts under. We all have T-shirts under. Yeah, isn't that interesting? We all grew up on TV being dressed by costumers.
They like to put a little collar T-shirt underneath the sweater. That's so true, we love T-shirts under our sweater. My T-shirt is a slight V. It's not really a V. If you want to get into it, this is a handkerchief. You know, when the Hogan family was over, that was a show I was in for a few years.
And I'm out, guys, I'm out. No, listen, so back in the Hogan family. We're not rolling yet. So when they were done with the show, they said, hey, would you like any of the wardrobe that your character wore? And I said, yeah, how much can I take? And they said, well, tell us what you don't want.
And I said, well, I'm not sure I don't want any of it. Can I have all of it? And they said, sure. So my whole wardrobe for, well, really, until I got with Amanda was all David Hogan stuff. Hogan family, and it still fit? Yeah, it did still fit for a bit. Would it fit now?
It would, yes. I think it would. You know what, the same thing they offered, well, now they offer, if you want any of the wardrobe, you have to buy it. Yeah, that's a really tacky thing, I think, that production companies are doing nowadays. I don't have that.
And they sell all the props and all the furniture and all the clothes. And it's like, hey, hey, let's easy with the tacky garage sale. Sean, I'll tell you, when we first did Arrested Development, hang on, I was getting to it. I just wanted to have a nice pause. When we were first doing Arrested Development, we used to, Jason and I, especially
amongst everybody in the cast, would have our sides. And for Tracy, I think we've been through sides. Oh, no, tell Tracy what sides are. Whatever scenes you're shooting that day, they print out those scenes so that you can have quick access to those scenes for your lines of dialogue. And they make them smaller if you'd like them to, so you can kind of carry them around easily.
And Jason and I would, we often had quite a bit of dialogue. We would quickly look at it, and then we'd be, especially in the model home set, we'd jam them in the couch, our sides, would they go rolling? Here we go, guys, we're rolling. We just couldn't take a last look at that one, and jam it in the couch to do the scene. So years later, we go back to start doing the Netflix season,
like season four, and they bring all, and they had some of that, all that old stuff that they had in storage, and they bring the couch. And Jason, I don't know if you remember, we, you and I went in the first day, we had to do like a 12-page two-person scene that was insane, that Mitch had changed the dialogue first day, and we were like, trying to remember,
get to the couch, and I'm like, huh, reach in. And there are all these sides in there, all these sides from like eight years before. We had a terrible housekeeper on the show. Yeah, we really did. We would do that too, like all around the set, we'd just like hide, line this up, I'd write him on the table, and you know,
Ted Danson's famous for keeping his script behind the bar. So if ever he looks down, he's looking at his pages. Oh really? But no kidding. He's not working the ice, huh? That was sometimes you might. Guys, let's get to it. What an extraordinary person we have today.
This little girl got her start on, This little girl got her start on a local puppet show called Hickory Hideout. And then because of that impressive credit, it made sense her next move would be on the hit NBC drama, Crossing Jordan, and then went on to steal scenes in Parks and Rec, Transparent, and on and on,
and in films she has incredible roles in How to Lose a Guy in 10 Days, Anchorman, tons of other great comedies, as well as amazing dramas like The Last Memsy, Revolutionary Road. But her latest gig, which I'm a huge fan of, was from the Marvel world, starring as the amazing villain,
Agatha Harkness in WandaVision. It's the illustrious Catherine Hawn, who I don't know. Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait, you guys. Oh, gosh. Our Catherine Hawn? Yeah, why is she your guest?
Our Catherine Hawn, you guys. Catherine, how dare you come in on Sean's list? Why, you should have called me and said, before I say yes to Sean, I just want to make sure you're good with me not being your guest. Well, I'm also really like, everything about this is cute.
First of all, that it's a paper towel that I was over your camera. Yeah, not just camera off, but just that I'm supposed to hold a paper towel. So I saw you're cute. Look at your all dressed the same today. Yeah, we dressed up for you today. We literally dressed exactly the same through this.
It's all of us dead, kind of. Look at all of us. Oh, yeah, you're in the same. Well, it's kind of rainy here, isn't it? Yeah, it's all cozy and rainy. Well, Sean, would you guys mind taking a tight 60 minute break and just let me hang out with Catherine for a bit?
Sure, sure, sure. I think I may like her more than both of you guys. Put together, yeah. We have a lot of catching up to do. We really do. I know, Catherine, I don't know. I think we met a long time ago. Come on, thank you for having me.
Yes, yes. We did. Yeah, a long time ago. And we share a very good mutual friend. Well, don't gloss over that. Where did you guys meet a long time ago? What was that event? You might remember it differently, but I remember it was like,
when I was doing Crossing Jordan, there was an NBC party, maybe at 30 Rock. Yeah, sure. And then we ended up at a bar called Names and Faces. Yeah. Sounds great. Right by what we used to call the Regal Beagle, the Regal Royale.
Was it called Names and Faces? Yes. It's right next to the act. Names and Faces. Jason would have, he has problems with both of those things. Yes. They don't let him in. They don't let him in.
Wait, Catherine, quick question. Just starting out to speed up your story, but how long did it take to cross Jordan? Oh, I'm still crossing Jordan. Okay, okay. No, she never got across. By the way. Seven seasons.
That's what kept it going. Just for the record. If I made that joke, Will wouldn't talk to me for a week. Yeah, Will makes it and I laugh my ass off. Well, it's how you make it. It depends on what time of the year you're gonna cross Jordan in.
If it's a winter, it's gonna get tough winters over there. Wait, you're in your house, but it looks like you're in a record store or something. What's happening? It does look, yeah, it does. You look like the... I don't know if I was just in a record store, you guys.
I'm living up my high fidelity dreams. Are you in the set of this? I'm in my garage, guys. I don't know what to tell you. What do you do? Paint or what's going on? Is it a gal cave? You guys, can I tell you a very funny story?
Is that Sean had asked me to do this before and I was the guest that had to bail last minute. That's okay. That was you. You had to bail last minute? I was in Serbia and it was late at night, my time. And my, my headphone jacks. This is my headphone, they wouldn't work.
And turns out, all I needed to do is... It should be noted that you just made the universal sign for... Master bass jacking off. Pulling a rope down, Jason. Well, needless to say, all I had to do was turn the computer on and off, apparently. But I was on such a frenzy
and your tech team was so patient with me. But it would have been really goddamn cute because I was shooting a film. We were having our rap party on the roof and the lead actor was like, you're not getting away with this. And so he had like brought, like in the middle of what would have been our podcast,
he like brought, it was Daniel Craig and he was gonna bring like force me to answer the door and get a glass of champagne during our podcast. Which would have been real goddamn cute. For the crossing Jordan movie? Yes. We were shooting it in Serbia. It's a long story, Will, but Daniel Craig's in it.
Is Jill Hennessey have anything to do with it? I shouldn't have said it. Crossing Jordan movie, everybody's been waiting. Names and faces. Faces and names. All right, Nat, haven't you done some light hanging with Mr. Bond? Daniel Craig, I did years ago.
We went to a Super Bowl party and then he said, let's go to... Hey, wait a second, Will. Did you just wake up from a nap? Look at the back of your head again. Hang on a second. I know, I did. Did you really?
I did. That's why he's on fire. Listener, it's three o'clock on a Monday and Will just got up. Can you tell me something, Will? Yeah, me too. You did, right? You guys are the worst.
You guys, I'm gonna shake it up for you. It really is. Don't wake them up yet. And I appreciate you doing this at a three o'clock on a Monday. Okay, let's get back to Serbia. I wanna go to Serbia. How was shooting in Serbia?
Quick trip. You were in Serbia with D Craig. What was it? It was Knives Out. We did some stuff there for the second Knives Out. Oh, great. Right. And third, right?
Just the second. But there's two and three, right? But there's gonna be a third. You get killed in the second one. There we go, spoiler alert. We got it. I love that movie. So, Catherine, you get shot or knifed?
You get knifed probably in the second one. But just blown up in the trunk of the car. No! Why are they shooting in Serbia? I can't say anything. No, Jason, what are you doing? By the way, in Australia, it's called That's Not a Knives Out.
That's Not a Knife. That's not a Knife. All right, so you're in part two, but not in part three. I mean, yeah. You don't know. We don't know. But they do a new cast for every, I guess, Knives Out. So, except for Daniel.
Daniel's the one connecting. But you're tech avail, LA. Listen, I will tell them I'm tech avail. Means technically available. Put a different wig on her. Who knows? How did you like working in Serbia? Serbia, this is what I'll tell you about.
I loved Serbia. However, I haven't been eating much meat lately. If you like day old cheese, pour it over dear Serbia. Is your place. I served you by a guy in a Sergio Tikini tracksuit like that, right? Oh my God, which are so rad. And let me tell you, I got a couple from my son,
and he is wearing them proudly. I can serve you this food, or also I might have a piece under here, too. Also, there's a lot of like, at baggage claim, people just full on smoking cigarettes inside, just waiting for their luggage in the airport. I mean, they smoke in the elevator in Serbia, I think. Yeah.
Oh yeah, for sure. Bless them. For sure. But it is, but it's actually like a gorgeous, like really beautiful, really beautiful graffiti. Will and I went to Istanbul, Turkey once, and when we got off the plane and in the airport, they put, I don't know why, they put us on that little truck
that drives you through the airport in the sea of, and I'm not exaggerating, a million people. Yeah, we go through. Like, beep, beep, beep, beep, and me and Joe. Did you guys look particularly bloated when you got off the plane or something? Why'd they put you on the truck? I don't know.
I don't know. Not everybody's worried about bloat 24-7, baby. And they don't put people on an ambulatory golf cart. Is it about the bloat? All right, so, Catherine, back to you. How long were you in Serbia for? Not that long. We were in Greece for a big chunk of it,
which was the best, which was awesome. That was like the beginning of the summer. And I was having it, and I'd never been there before, and I literally got there and I felt like, immediately I was like 67 years old, just like with an overall strap off. I was just like, I was like, I was Mamma Mia City. I loved it so much.
In Greece. I was so into it. I was like, leather up the skin. Like, I was so down. I loved it. What part of Greece were you in? There's some great spots in Greece. Yes, we were in a really off the beaten path,
kind of like three hours north, or I guess maybe, I guess it was more, it was like three hours outside of Athens. It kind of felt like the big syrup. So you're coming off the main highway. Catherine, you think our listener doesn't know, they don't know shit about anything. Are the people dumb enough to listen to this?
I love your listeners. Especially Tracy. I want to hear your idea of listeners. Tracy's got, well, how did she get so dumb? Tracy, I'm with you. It's pretty good. She's part of the football. Why are they so cruel to you?
We loved Tracy. We love her. We took little, we took little air, we took little taxis to like, Spetsis or Hydra were islands we visited. We never went to like the party islands. Did the kids or Ethan make it out there? Yeah, they were with me the whole time.
Come on. Oh, that's nice. Yeah, and then Leonard and Ethan went, they went home early, so they could, you know, Leonard could have his first, like the camp, sleepover camp. How's that going? 15 for him, right?
Which you said 15? Yeah, it's good. Actually like much better than middle school. I don't know if you feel the same, but I feel like a cloud like lifted. Middle school is tough. Middle school is rough. It's rough.
I'm glad that Franny missed the bulk of that. She missed seventh and eighth. And I think, aren't they both in the same class? They're the same class. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Middle school or what Jason calls high school, right? It was the same, yeah.
Or just the end. Middle school was. For me, yeah. Yeah. Or not even. Almost made it, is what I call high school. Jason, don't you dare. Well, listen, I was busy chasing my passion.
You were earning. Yeah, I was doing some fifties dance in Teen Wolf 2. Somebody said, hey, here's your diploma. And Jason said, what do I need a diploma for? He sped off in a 9-11, you know? So. And all went downhill. Catherine, listen, I want to talk to you about your start
and everything because I'm really interested in that and you grew up. Let's get the interview started. It's 20 minutes in already, Sean. I know. We gotta get to it. Sean, and by the way, Sean is our top interviewer on this program.
Oh, God. Oh, I know. You guys, I love this dude. I love your podcast, by the way. Love it, so happy. Because you've got the world's greatest host on it. Go ahead, he willed right in. It is the worst.
Go ahead, tell Catherine. I mean, I'm the best. The world's nominated, go ahead. Sean, here he comes. Here comes one of his award-winning questions. Oh, God. How old were you when you started to act? Did your parents want you to get started?
How do you memorize all those lines? Don't start. Catherine, you know, the three of us host this thing. And the nice folks at iHeartRadio gave us a few nominations for their annual podcast recognition. Oh, they should have. And they singled out, young Sean P. Hayes, for host of the year.
The worst part is that Sean sent us the article. Oh, he did. And I didn't read it. Under the caption of, good for us. Good for us. Exclamation point. And then Will said, sounds like good for you. And he goes, oh, I didn't read it all.
I didn't read it. I really didn't read it. Sean. Yeah, isn't that hilarious? And I'm like, check out the pictures of these Emmys. Oh, I didn't know I sent that. All right, so how'd you get started was the question, right, Sean?
So how early? No, no, I want to know. Hang on, one second, I actually have a question. So when you come from a family where there's three kids, and we kind of ask this question a lot, because I'm interested. I was the youngest of five. A lot of people who are the youngest of siblings
feel they need the attention for the actor. But you were the oldest of three, which is rare. So what gives? So what? Yeah. What's with the French show in your life? Yeah, hey, weirdo. What?
Well, too much of a big shot to stick around and be an example for the young kids, huh? You had to get out of there. Sorry, Katherine, go ahead and finish swallowing your drink. Oh, my god. We almost got our first pet take. Almost.
So even though you were the oldest, why did you get into showbiz? I'm actually interested in that question. I love you. Me too. You know, I grew up going to Catholic school. It was more of like a cultural thing for us than anything else. It was like the cheapest private school, to be honest.
And every Saturday, I would take classes at the Cleveland Playhouse, which has now kind of been mostly taken over by Case Western, the big hospital down there. But it was just like the most. I thought you were going to say mostly taken over by kangaroos or something. It's been mostly, now it's been overrun by kangaroos. What?
Yeah, no, I know. It's a long story. That's exactly what I was thinking too, Sean. Yeah, thanks. I thought you almost said kangaroos. Katherine, please just go ahead. Please go on. I'm so silly today.
It's because it's later. I love a matinee, guys. Now the matinee is yielding real fruit. Turns out the matinee is the only way to do it. OK, so the kangaroos are in the gym. What a clown show this is. What a. So far we can't use any of it.
None of it's usable. We're 25 minutes in. OK. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. OK, so you found a passion there at the Catholic School for acting. And then, OK, so what was the first big job?
What did you, when did you know? I might be able to make a living at this. OK, my first big job. I played Salty the Psalm book. And it was a, I played a Psalm book at the church. It was like, I wore a cardboard box, and they painted it to look like a Psalm book. Oh, no.
And I kind of stood in the middle of the church, and I would dance around. And it was like, apparently, it's a thing that they do in churches. I thought that it was just like a singular, you know, that we had written it for our, you know, for Saint Hans. But apparently, like, it goes, it's something that is in a lot of different, like, fundamental
churches throughout the country. But I played Salty. Sean, you're familiar with this? No, not that. P-S-A-L-T-Y. Pasalty. Oh, I get it. Pasalty the Psalm book.
Psalm book. And you felt like you nailed that particular piece, such that. No, I had a lot more to learn, Jason Bayman. Did you end up doing Psalm like it hot? Did you, did you guys ever do that? I mean, something's got to give. And this guy cannot get a nomination, OK? It's unbelievable.
Now, that's high level shit right there. Hey, hey, you couldn't come within a mile of a joke like that. No, absolutely not. Fucking. I say kangaroos, and it goes cricket. Catherine, keep talking. I want to know, you went back to, you went to Northwest. From kangaroos to crickets, the Shawnee story.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. It's so stupid. This is my favorite. That's the worst. OK, so Catherine, wait a minute. I can't tell. You have to fire your publicist after this, Catherine. No.
So wait, you went to. Then I went to the Cleveland Playouts, and I just took classes, I was called a curtain puller there. But I didn't actually, apparently back in the day, they used to be able to pull the curtains. This is going to be such a boring story. No. But then I didn't get to.
Well, walk us through it. OK, wait. And then you went to Northwestern. I know so many people that went to Northwestern University. It seems like so many famous people come out of there or went there, right? Did you love it there? Oh, sorry.
Jumping forward to Northwestern. Sorry. Yeah. OK. That was about a 15-year jump. But I'm with it. Go ahead. Please.
Sorry. The job, she didn't get to pull the curtain, Jason. Right, right, right. And then we went to Northwestern. Unless you got another, what other jobs have you not gotten? OK, listen, I played, listen, in the middle there, in the middle there, I did Hickory Hideout. Yes, Hickory Hideout was the first, it was your puppet show.
Yes. How old were you when you did that? I was in fourth grade to sixth grade. And it was at our local news station. And we shared the space so they would like, it was, the tree house was always in the corner. And then on Saturdays, when they weren't doing the evening news, they would just roll out the tree house.
I got to see footage of that. And it was me and two squirrels named Nutso and Shirley Squirrely. And an owl, puppet named Know-it-Owl. I loved that joke. And I played a character named Jenny. And I would knock on the tree house. And we would ask Nutso and Shirley.
That sounds like a hoot. Yeah, Nutso. Beautiful. Now there, hey, who's in the game now? Good for you, Sean. Look who's thrown his hat in the ring. You know who watched that? You know who will watch that?
Owl. Oh my god. Somebody just passed you. Boy, did you see him go by you there, Will? What he's hitting for the cycle right now. That was unbelievable. Whittly gets to by at the end of the episode. Barely keep up.
Go ahead, Catherine. So yeah, let's get to Northwestern. Fuck the tree house. You're six years old now. You're at Northwestern. So what happens at Northwestern? You go to some Wildcat games? I did not take in one Wildcat game.
But I met my husband. There we go. Oh, that's nice. My friend, my friend, my husband. How'd that go? Tell me about the first date. God, we. Hurry, goddammit.
Because somebody shot at me real fast. We. Are you talking about the date? I remember we. Oh, Jesus. Sorry, we can cut that. I'm trying to get in on the quick jokes. Cut it.
We're going to double it. Can I get in on the quick jokes? Double it, you guys. We were at the cafeteria. His plate was, I remember his tray was very neat. Mine was a disaster. Because I wanted to try everything on the buffet. That sounds like mine.
And he was very neat. I made a lot of fun of him. And the rest is history. Wait, so he was sliding. I honestly want to know this. So you guys are filling up your tray. You're next to each other in the line there? Or did you see him sitting alone at a table for one?
No, he was not sitting. No, he was not. OK, so you're sliding down the thing together. And you start making small talk while you're scooping stuff onto your plate. No, we had arrived at a table where there were other people sitting. And I was like, Jesus, because his tray was so
neatly neat. And that was not a turn on or it was? It was. It was interesting to me because I had to try everything as if I had never been fed before in my life. I had piled everything that the cafeteria had offered onto my tray.
You wanted to get your money's worth. Absolutely. Did he have his great hair back then? Great hair. He's got great hair. Really, really great. Doesn't he have beautiful hair? Beautiful hair.
Great hair. Now, when did you, because this is what I really want to know, you worked at a beauty salon. You've got to have like crazy, awesome, funny beauty salon like stories. Was that while you were in college, you worked at a beauty salon? It was after college, moved to New York,
skipping ahead, worked at a hair salon called Garen New York that was out of Henry Bendall. So this was in 95. Copy. He was like one of those hair cutters that were charging like $300 for a haircut. And you were like, where was it? Where was the?
What? I know that name, Harry. Where was his? Henry Bendall. It used to be on Fifth Avenue. It was like a very fancy little tea. It was like a crock, like Bergdorf's was right there. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And were you assisting this stylist, not a hair cutter? No. They don't like to be called that. I was the receptionist. OK. My cousin George gave me the job. OK. My cousin George gave me the job.
Would you dabble with nails or hair or anything? No. In fact, I wore the same Banana Republic suit there every day, so much so that it turned shiny because I had to dry clean it so much. Do you know how you like? Oh, yeah, yeah. All the dudes got together to get me a Mason Pearson hair
brush for the holidays one year because they were like, brush your hair. Because I was such a disaster working at the front desk. Because I would literally be like, I remember they would kind of try to experiment on me. Like, Sweet Garen gave me like Anne Bancroft, like Skunk Stripes, and Ethan. We had been living in like a one room, fifth floor walk-up,
near Scores, so like on the east side. I don't know where that is. Right, right. It's a sports place, right? Anywhere near names and faces. Names and faces, faces and names. So because Sean jumped in, you and Ethan, you meet in the line at the cafeteria,
and all of a sudden now you're living in New York together. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Sean, what? Because he just wants to hear about stories about people crapping their pants at the salon. But you know what I mean? Like, let's. No, you know where I'm going with this.
I want to know about theater in New York. Yeah, things went well in Northwestern with you and Ethan. And you said, hey, let's go east. Let's go to New York because I've got a passion for theater. And it seems like you have a passion for hair, Ethan. So why don't I get a job at a hair salon? No, that we kind of looked in the village voice
when we were at Northwestern that summer after graduating. We saw that there was like a hotel that was $60 a night. And we were like, great, got a U-Haul, went, saw the hotel, put our stuff in storage, saw the hotel. It was the Jane Street Hotel. Oh, yeah. Pre.
Pre-cool. Head wig. Yeah. So it was like pre-becoming like a hip place. It was rough. Yeah. It was like my mom was like, bring flip flops because she was so afraid I was going to get like planters warts
from the shower. Sounds like me. And I was like flip flops because the water, the standing water in the shower was like three inches high. Why would you check into a hotel $60 a night as opposed to like an apartment for, I don't know, $300, $400 a month at that time? Because we didn't even know the city.
We went so blindly, like just like, we're going to go there. We're going to stay in this hotel until we find an apartment. These dirty hippies. Good with anything. Oh, good. Like my cousin George is going to get me a job. Ethan's working at Starbucks.
Like it's all going to happen. Right. It was crazy. And did it have, how fast was it? Did it start happening? No. So you were auditioning for stuff, I would imagine. It didn't start happening for a really long time.
I mean, I started, I was auditioning like, you know, I had like off, off, off, off, off, off, off, off, Broadway, you know, that crab like that was like, you can do it if you find 12 people. Yeah. To pay to come see it. Right, right, right. Yeah.
And like, what, what, what, what, what was the first thing that like gave you some money and, and, and, and used like, okay, I can make a living at this. I no longer have to work the reception desk at the beauty salon. I mean, we started going to Williamstown. Yeah. I probably did like seven summers there, which was pretty life changing.
Right. Williamstown, they do a lot of theater there, yeah. Yeah. And then I got that doesn't pay. No, it doesn't pay. In fact, no, it doesn't pay at all. But then I got into Yale and I went to grad school for acting. That also doesn't pay, which does not pay.
And in fact, I put myself when you came out, did you get something that was, I came out with a holding deal. There it is. And I, that's when I got crossing. George was through the holding deal is when they pay you money so you don't audition anywhere else. They, yeah, they basically own you, which is, it's good.
Yeah. Well, you know, then it was great. It is. Yeah. Well, especially in a fake old business, you get a guaranteed check. It's, it's nice. So Catherine, you know, I love horror theater horror stories.
And I know these guys love them too, but they'll say they don't. Sorry. Horror. You're saying horror. OK. And so tell these guys the story about some clinking glasses or something or cheersing something. Didn't you have a horror theater story about like in a scene,
somebody was cheersing now? Didn't you, Catherine, you got something about, there's a cheers story. Didn't you have clink glasses or something funny stuff? Go fuck. You're going to, it's not, you're not going to win it, Sean. They're listening right now. The people making their decisions.
Sean, you have. It's been narrowed down to five people now. You believe what I do. It's just you against. We'll have fun. OK. We're just jealous that Sean got one. I was in a play.
Yeah. Come on, guys. It's the host of the year. I'm sorry. It's bitterness. It hurts. I know. It does.
OK. It was, I was in a play with, I was in my one and only Broadway play was called Bowing Bowing. Oh, yeah. I remember that. Yeah. It was, do you? Well, I remember not buying, I remember going, nope.
Oh. Yeah, yeah, not buying tickets to it, you know. But promises, promises. Yes, yes. Yes, yes. No, no, no, all jokes aside, I remember when that was yes on Broadway. So that was your first, that was your one and only.
That was a big hit. My first and only, but the cast was like crazy. It was Mark Rylandson, Whitford, and Miriam McCormick, and it was Christine Baransky. It was a great experience, and it was like a farce. Mark Matthew Ward constructed it. It was like a big old farce, and I think that's what we mean. Like, we had to cheers each other every night,
and so I just always did, like, there were so many times I did it with such force, like poor, like, fucking Mark would be so annoyed at me. And then I had to do this thing where I flashed him every night. But so from the audience's perspective, they just saw, like, the towel, and they just saw his reaction. But then we all wanted to just, to make Mark break, because he was such an easy laugh.
No, like, he's such an easy laugh. It was hilarious. So, like, one night I would just, like, take Bradley Whitford's headshot, and I cut it into a triangle, and I just taped it down there. I was like, just, we would just do this stupidest crap to try to make him laugh. And then he would just, like, lean into it.
So, like, our stage manager would be like, oh, okay, like, it would, the show, the duration time would be, like, would be, like, 20 minutes longer. Screwing around time. I mean, it would be, like, depending on how the audience was, it would just, it was hilarious.
All Mark. But he's, like, you know, he's a shaman, I think. I think he's so gifted. Actor's actor. An actor's actor. So, this is not a great question and a tough one, I'll bet you, but your star is rising with the bullet. And I'm sure that all, you know,
they want you to continue to be the funniest thing on screen and steal all the scenes and stuff, but then you're also getting these parts, probably, that are maybe even the lead on something where it's not always maybe that funny, and are you battling sort of the decision between, like, do I continue to take these parts where I can really score,
or do I take these larger parts that I less score, but I'm in more of it? And, like, how do you, are you strategizing about your future, or what kind of stuff you want to do? I mean, I don't know. This is why I don't get nominated for fucking a husband. Oh, stop it! But I mean, I've always, like...
Go ahead. Did I say any of that out loud? You guys. After I was done with the question, did you hear me talking at all? Unfortunately, the question was out loud. That's an awesome question. I mean, I, I like, I mean, I feel like
I've been able to do some stuff that kind of lands in the middle of all of it. So that's the kind of stuff that I'm the most attracted to anyway. So if it happens to be a lead, it happens to be a lead, but it also can be supporting. You know, Katherine, you're in this sort of elite group of actors, and I put you in there, a lot of,
and it's not that big of people. You're always, always, always good, no matter what the thing is. In every single thing you do. You're like John Goodman in that way. You're like, it's a very small group. Oh my God, that is the most flattering comparison. Yeah, like Meryl Streep, like all those people.
But no, you're always good. And you know, you're not gonna phone it in like a Bateman or a Hayes. You're gonna deliver every time, you know? No, you're gonna phone it in like a Narnette. So the, just a little bit more about the career stuff because I think you're such a fascinating actress. And I think you, do you feel now
that you're finally getting the attention you deserve? Sure, you're always working, but now you're kind of more in the spotlight than ever. It feels like from my perspective, from someone who, you know, who watches your work and admires you, it just seems like finally, like I've been a life fan, but it feels like finally the press is catching up to you.
Do you feel that as well? I mean, WandaVision was not so. Like that was crazy. I've never experienced anything like that. So that was boggers. And it was certainly, it's interesting because it was certainly not the thing that I thought would have been the thing.
You know, you just never fricking know. Yeah, it's massive. But it seems like people are finally taking notice in the best way. And I don't know, from my perspective, at least. Do you have something when you're working, do you have a big peeve about the process or the way that things are getting made
that you just don't adhere to? That you're just like, you know what? That really doesn't work for me. I mean, I do, like I guess it would be like in the hair and makeup trailer when someone comes in and is doing like a voice memo really loudly that everyone else has to shut up for. It's always really fricking annoying.
Or just walking in on a face time. Yeah, it's just kind of like, guys, you can step outside. Like now the whole trailer has to be kind of quiet. It's always a little, and also just pick up your clothes. Like, and maybe that comes from the theater, but I'm always like, hang your fricking costumes up. Like, it's not that big of a deal. I agree with that.
Well, hang on. Are you sharing a trailer with somebody? Do you need a better representation? I don't know. We always share trailers. I mean, it's a different level. Aline, negotiate you at least a triple banger or something? Yeah, but our triple bangers are just,
it's just one long car. And then we're all just kind of bouncing around. That was the other title of our podcast was triple banger. Triple banger. It would have been good. Don't you think in general, though, face times need to happen when you're alone?
You can't, if you're in a group of people, you cannot use face time, right? Isn't that imposing on other people's space? Because I also feel like, naturally, the human voice gets louder when we're on face time. Right. And it's just like a little bit performative. And then when other people are around,
yeah, I'm with you. Yeah, I don't want to be a part of your conversation. You probably are not with me on this, but I hate phones on sets. Yeah, well, of course. I do, too. Who likes it? Well, to sort of fill the gaps in between
when you're working and not working? You should not, because I think it takes you out of it. And I used to try to institute a rule and said, no. Because now you look around, and if everybody's there, you look at everybody in every department is on there. Where's the small talk? Where's everybody hanging out together? Like, we got to be making whatever, ensemble.
Either go back to your trailer or just hang out. It feels like, it bumps me out sometimes. I agree. But, Catherine, if there was a no phone rule on set, do you think that you'd be great about generating, maintaining all of that small talk? Are you good at small talk? Are you a sociable person?
I am good at leaving when I need to and coming back when I need to. Like, I go to my trailer for lunch and recharge. Yeah. Do you nap at lunch, ever? Do you ever nap? Really good at a power nap. Same.
We just did it before you came on. Will, didn't Barry Sonofil teach you how to nap on set? Yeah, he told me one day after coming back from lunch, he was like, now you gotta nap, didn't you? I go, honey, and he goes, I can tell by your face is buffing. And he goes, you got a nap sitting up. And I was like, thanks a lot.
Like, I mean, while he's like, all right, let's start shooting. I'm like, I'm not gonna shoot with this face. Are you crazy? Naps sitting up like a cow. Let's do my angle last. Anyway, I do, I nap sitting up. And we will be right back.
All right, back to the show. Katherine, other than your beautiful family, what, how do you balance life from work? You have like hobbies and stuff like that. Hmm. Yeah. Sean, did you just give up? Mm-hmm, yep.
You know why? You know why? Cause I'm sweating my balls off. Are you? Hi, honey, it's hot in there. Oh my God, it's so hot. And Scotty's not in here. And I don't know how to change this.
Oh, you're in New York, right? Three steps. You're in New York. Don't go and change it, don't go and change it. You have to suffer. Get up and change the thermos. This is incredible. Okay, okay, while he's gone.
Do you have any hobbies? While he's gone. No, he's putting a bad God down. Sean, go do it, go adjust it. Sean, go adjust it. I just did it. What was it at? What was the thermos at at?
75. 75? What do you go, a monster? I'm like drenched. Sweating my balls off. Hey, do you have any hobbies? You like it cold over there, Katherine? Yeah, we keep it a little chilly over here.
Not gonna lie. I love it. Yeah. Sean, let's get back to your hobby question. Yeah, so let me ask you a different way. So Katherine, you know, other than your beautiful family, how do you fill the time in between gigs because I'm always looking for great ideas.
Okay, thanks, Sean. Katherine. Thanks, Sean. Katherine. I, I mean, listen, between gigs, it is mothering an existential crisis until the next gig. Yeah, all right. Right.
Katherine, I'm sorry about this. You know, it's just, if we didn't like you and know you so well, we'd actually have a decent interview here, but we don't want to do a decent interview. We want to fuck around with our panel. We just want to fuck around. Let's just fuck around, guys.
It's fine. It's a rainy Monday. I love you. I'm so grateful that Sean, you asked me to do it. Well, listen, Katherine, talk. I want to know a bit. Let's get to five questions. I think we're at about three questions.
Let's get two more good quality questions. Here's what I want to know. Here's what I want to know about you. I want to know about your sensibility. What is your favorite film of all time? You have like a film or like it's sort of an area that you like that you go- A touchstone.
Yeah. What would you say it would be? I would say- And don't be cool. And don't be cool and don't be like- Dust Boots. You know, like, yeah. By the way, Dust Boots is a great film.
Dust Boots is a great movie, but also intense. I mean, I would say, I mean, listen, Woman of the Influence is incredible movie, but I also love E.T. Great. I love E.T. That's a great answer. A little bit of the both.
That's a great answer. And when you were a kid, who would you watch movies and TV and go, God, I'd kill to have her career. I'd kill me just like her. Oh, Terry Gar. Nice pause. There you go. I just watched Tootsie last night.
By the way, you've nailed it. But you've nailed it. Yeah, you have to. You know that I have independent of ever knowing that you said that. I've referenced you as Terry Gar a thousand times. Is that true? Are you serious?
On my kid's life, both of them. Yep. That's crazy. Quick to put stuff on your kid's life. I've noticed that. Because you said it a few times. And Captain. Wait, Sean, you just watched Tootsie recently.
I just watched Tootsie last night. And did it hold on? Did it hold on? Oh my God, it's one of the best movies of all time. It's like one of the best movies. It's flawless. It's a perfect movie. But getting back to my earlier dumb question,
that's, now, Terry Gar didn't really have a lot of lead roles in her life, did she? No, but again. Do you want that, I guess, is my question. Yes, of course. I also love like, Gina Rowland's, forget it. Forget it. Are there any roles that you get offered?
And because of their, maybe they lean towards more obvious, they lean towards the sexuality of a woman. And you're just like, God, I don't want to do those things. Is there stuff you turn down right away? No. I think I've done it all. I mean, I've definitely done, I've been afforded in this weird chapter like post-kids.
I've been able to do some juicy, tell some juicy stories that have not been just like, there's this movie I did called Private Life, which I'm like crazy, super proud of. It's me and Giamatti. Yeah, Paul Giamatti, what was that like? How was he? He was great.
I love him. I think my favorite experience, and it's about a couple that's like, it's Tamara Jenkins. And it's a couple that's going through like their, it doesn't sound funny, but it's funny. The couple going through their IVF journey. But it's like really funny. And it's also horribly heartbreaking.
Right. And like, you know, I love Dick was something that was like a different, like a whole different like. Keep it to the movies. Keep it to the movies you like. Okay, we're not going into general likes. We're not going to go into general likes. Just keep it to the movies, Catherine.
No, you don't. Jesus Christ. My poor children. But like, so yeah, I mean, of course I'm attracted to like the, that I, there's nothing that I'm like, if it's an interesting story and whatever. How are you managing all of this work though with you, I know you love your husband and your kids too.
Like, but you say they went to Serbia with you. They did not go to Serbia. They went to Greece. Then they, then I was gone for a little bit. And then I came home and I was like, nothing, I'm here. I mean, you know how, I mean, you know how it is. It's like you're gone for a chunk. Right.
But the ratio like, I don't think I've, have you guys declared the ratio that you're going to spend away from home versus at home? I mean, I guess we can't really, right? You just kind of kind of go from job to job. Yeah. But you know what sucks? It's just that they need you the more the older they get.
I know it. They need you around. And yet the older they get, the harder it is for them to travel with you because they're involved with their social continuity and their educational, you know, consistency and all of that stuff. Yeah.
So it's like really big, big, everyone is a big decision now for sure. Cause of all that stuff. What about dream role? Is there something that you've always wanted to play and you just haven't got a chance yet? Or are you like, I want to play this. I guess I'm going to have to write it for myself
cause it'll never be offered to me, anything like that. I mean, I guess like, you know, I guess there's just a woman. Nancy Reagan. Nancy Reagan. Yeah. Nancy Reagan. And everyone's lest.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Very complex. I'm going to be allowed to, but I really would love to play Nancy Reagan. There we go. You know, but I think I, you know, like any, a woman like just as she's aging,
like in the juicy complexity of it is to be a person in a woman's body that's getting older and older and older. Like, I, you know, if I could continue to have those parts to show, like all the nooks and crannies of. Right. Yeah. Because as we age, we get to play more interesting characters
where some actors think, Oh God, as I get older, all the good parts are gone or they're not going to hire me as much cause I'm getting older. Well, it's actually where all the good parts are. That's what I have found in my career. Oddly is the more interesting my life has been post 40, which is like, I really think
I want to tell this young actors that are panicked. Like you just never fricking know, like all the society was telling me, like, once you have kids, you're, you're done. Like as a, especially as a woman, like you're done. Right. But that's old thinking though. That doesn't exist.
That's old thinking. You know, I used to have an acting teacher who used to say he hated child actors. He's like, what do they have to draw on? They have no experience. These people, they're born, they have no, and it's the same thing with young, a lot of young character.
Who gives a shit? You know what I mean? Now, of course that's saying that as a guy who's getting older was a middle-aged guy who still plays 30, but like, you know, that that's, that's my, you know, barely. And, you know, who's an icon for the young people. But, you know, and I could go on and on and on.
No, you don't have to. We got it. What do you think the youngest Will Arnett could play, Catherine? Be honest and be kind. No, you don't have to be kind. Be honest. I mean, let's really be honest here.
What is he, I'll start. We'll go around. We'll be my turn and then we'll go for each of us. No, we're not going to start with you. In fact, I don't even think you get to respond to this. I would honestly say that I could honestly cast you as a 32 year old guy. I could, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I was going to say that. I was going to, I was to be totally honest. I was going to say 36. Yeah. Now, not, I don't, I just want to be honest. Cause we were talking about that before. This is the greatest day of my life. I would say all four of us could play in our 30s.
Could we not? Are we nuts? Are we nuts? Listen, I've, I've seen 50 year old people. And I don't, I don't, I, they look, I'd look a lot older than you will. Thank you. Do you know what's interesting?
Remember the show, The Golden Girls? Yeah. They were all, weren't they all, I'm going to get this wrong. God bless. Weren't they all in their fifties, but we were made to believe they were older than that? Or were they in their forties even maybe?
Come on. I wish there was a way we could find out information quickly. Guys, I've got a computer over here. You want to hold on a second? I want to find that out, The Golden. Hey, Catherine, let me ask you, let me, let me ask you the last great question.
Have you done an interview worse than this? They're in their fifties. Have you ever been interviewed by three dumber, less prepared? I have never done an interview that has been more entertaining and charming. None less interesting. And just vague. Yeah.
Vague. And just vague. That's what we're going to call this. Completely vague. Yeah. That's what it is. It's just charming as hell. There's no beginning.
There's no middle. There's no end. Which I love. It's kind of like life. Yeah. But this was just a slice of life. Yeah. Big finish, Sean.
Big finish. What's your best question on the list? No, I don't need any more questions because she's going to come visit me in my apartment in New York City. Is that true? And I'm going to ask her, I'm going to make her. And I'm going to ask her questions without these two knobs.
We'll go to, maybe we'll go to names and faces. Well, but what about for Tracy? One last good one for Tracy. One last good one for Tracy. She's very disappointed in this interview. And she really wants to end it. Tracy, don't be disappointed, Tracy. It's a lot of fun.
Give her one more, Sean. We're having a lot of fun. It was a rainy, cozy, bad day. Here's one that I love. Here's one that I ask often because I am always interested. Kids want to do what mom does or no. No. Or dad.
Oh, actually, my son. Oh my God, you guys, I almost just burped right in the microphone. You almost threw up on the mic. I almost made myself laugh when the paper was over it at the very beginning because I was like, what if I just had cut the loudest part while you guys were just doing it? If you had laughed with your tiny little snort,
I would have known exactly who it is. Okay, there it is. My son wants to, like, as of right now, he's really in a film. He's in a film class. He's like, really into it. It's a lot of psychological horror going on. Yeah, uh-oh.
Can I ask you a question? And this is gonna seem somewhat serious. What drew you to the cinema? Just to finish this off. Catherine, thank you for your time today. Sorry, somebody needs to be. Sean, Sean. No, that's it.
So, Catherine, listen. You guys, I just, I don't want to think ahead, but I feel like this is your submission for next years. Absolutely. The podcast was. This is gonna get Will and I in the conversation. We're gonna have more of the conversation. This is gonna be the submission.
Thank you for the time in your garage that you gave us. Hopefully they let you back in the house. Get back to framing more posters. Sure. I got that. Sorry, what is the turnaround on a poster? Like, it's just a regular poster size. If I bring it in.
If I get it in the mail. It's quick. Okay, because if I do a curbside, if I do a curbside drop-off in the morning, can I get the same day? Can I get the same day? Really? Three hours.
Plastic or glass? Wow. It doesn't matter? I prefer plastic. Sure. You got it. I got it. It's better for the environment.
It's not taking a little tacky. Catherine. Catherine, I can't do another hour. I know our audience couldn't, but I could. I know. I love you guys so much. Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
There was nothing about this hour that I didn't love. Other than you can't get it back. You're a mega talent. You are a mega talent and we worship you. Worship back. Thank you so much for all of this. Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah. Okay.
Bye, sweetie. Robin Bennett, do I stay on? Flip it. You slam your laptop closed. Bye. I'm finding you all. Bye, Catherine. Love you.
Bye. You know what? If you're a fan of the show, if you listen to the show and then you come on the podcast, feel free at the end of the interview to just slam your laptop shut. Because we will have new fan respect for you. Yeah. That's the move.
It's the mic drop. Just slam it shut. But what if you're on a desktop? You walk away. You just gotta walk away. Just give up and cut the power to your house. Stick your gun back on your camera. Go outside the bed and just cut the power.
Guys, but I have to. Sean, listen, I think that might have been one of our worst interviews. Yes. Because we just wouldn't get on track. I was trying. And I gotta blame you for that. No, no, I was trying.
You're guest. You gotta keep us on the list. Was it our fault? You feel like it was our fault. No, no, a little bit. But listen, I think that it was also, I think it was a Monday matinee. We were all a little giddy,
plus then you get the fourth giddiest person on the planet. I know. So we all had a really good time. It was probably not our, not definitely not our worst. It was our probably our most silliest, which is more fun than I thought. Let me tell you, this is what it's like working with her. Have you guys worked with her yet?
No, I have not had the pleasure. You just can't get anything done because it's just too much fun hanging out with her. You don't wanna get serious and say, okay, okay, hold it, hold it, okay, okay. Now let's, rolling please. Yeah, but she, I really have been such a fan for a long time.
I've seen almost everything she's done and I've always kind of felt like we'd be friends because she's so- I was just gonna say that. I don't have a lot of female friends, but if I could count three, she would be one of them. Why do you think that is? I don't know.
I do. Why? Uh-oh, why? Here it comes. Because I think that your personality is kind of grating. Okay, okay. No, no, listen, don't let him keep going, Shawn. No, that was it.
No, no, that was it. That's a full stop. Oh, there wasn't a qualifier on that? Especially towards, it's grating towards women. Oh. Men tolerate it. Sorry, that should have said that. Towards women, I think women find your personality.
So you're saying the reason I don't have a lot of female friends is because they don't wanna be friends with me. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Because of your personality. I thought I had a choice. I thought. I thought.
I thought. I thought. I thought. I thought. Got it. Okay. Okay. That's not true.
That's not true. By the way, that's not true. Is it at a level that I could maybe, could I work on it? Or is it a little too heavy? That's not for us. Work on your personality. You've been working on it for 52 years, pal.
Sorry. What are you gonna do now? Okay. You know? No, I will say this. You have a lot of, you do have a lot of female friends. That's not true.
You have Catherine. Yes, what do you mean? No, but I mean like close, tight, like just call them up. Like here's how my day's been going kind of thing. Well, like I have, as you know. You do? My wife's one of them.
Well, your wife is one of my close friends and she's a female and she and I talk on the phone or FaceTime often. Right. I am, I love Amanda. I am friends with both sexes because I am non-threatening. That's not, one of my favorite things that Sean does,
and he likes to do this a lot at dinner. He does this a lot at Jen's because Jen often has candles on the table, as we know for dinner. Sean, I'll go, he'll pick up one of the candles. And he goes, which way is the bathroom? He protects the candle like an old time.
Like I'm screwed. Like yeah. Which way is the bathroom? And he walks like if he's going through like a haunted mansion. All this bit in the world. Or I'll pick up literally any purse that a woman left behind. I'll pick it up and go,
I'm running to Ralph's. Anybody need anything? Remember we were at this dinner and Tyke has shown up and he had that, he had like Joseph's Technicolor coat and it was really. Shame coat, he had a lot of colors and stuff like that. And he came in and he put it on the chair.
And then Sean and Scott, he got up to leave like 20 minutes later and all of a sudden, Sean comes in the room and Sean's wearing it. He goes, anyway, guys, I'm going, Tyke goes, hang on a second. And he goes, I came with this.
I walked in with this. He went, I walked in with this. He's a nice guy. Tyke Latiti. Gosh, he's talented. Anyway, Catherine Hahn. Let me just say, Sean, thank you for getting Catherine on the show.
Yeah. She is one of those just mega wattage talents. And I meant it that she is always, always good. It's so good. It's so true. And you know what? There's, there aren't, like you said,
there aren't a lot of actors out there that it doesn't matter what the material is. If it's the material is great or it's just kind of not so great. She always shines in everything. I couldn't agree with you more. And I think she's just hilarious. Hilarious.
She really is. She just sparkles. And a really, in a really, really nice person too. Like a very genuine, nice person, real family. Nice talent that people work a lot. Forget working with, even just hanging out with her, it's almost impossible. Like this interview was tough,
just getting through because she's so much fun and you just want to laugh and just have a conversation. Yeah. It's like we were at a restaurant or something. Yeah. You never want to get serious. Yeah. I love it.
I, her, if she ever had an autobiography, she should call it, honestly. Uh-huh. Oh, I get it. I get it. I get it. And that would be the title of her. Yiee.
Bye. Autobi. Oh, look at me. All right. Smart. Smart. Smart. Last.
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Last. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery
Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.